ciao benvenuti nello studio della casa
nuova probabilmente sentirete l'audio un
attimo strano è perché ancora da mettere
a posto e da riempire ancora un po il
tetto spiovente e quindi l'audio
rimbalzo in modo strano comunque solite
cose e benvenuti anche che la casa nuova
è sì perché sto traslocando in questi
giorni sono stato senza internet col st
parole da tutte le parti la definizione
esatta di trasloco puzza di bruciato 40
da ottimo e siamo qui per fare che e
agosto tutti si prendono una vacanza
tutti youtuber vanno in vacanza io
vorrei che ciò tutte ste vacanze a
prendere visto che non è che abbia fatto
tutti sti grandi video però sai con
pausa ho ricominciato un po il ritmo
probabilmente ciccia fuori agosto e
quindi non si fa più niente ma io invece
qualcosa che voglio fare
voglio far parte della nuova generazione
di youtube quelli che fanno i blog
perché adesso le punte di diamante
youtube italia non sono più i che player
i recensori chi fa i video comici sketch
comici no sono i flanker giovani
frizzanti che fanno 300 400mila visual
convegno tipo cosa c'è nella mia borsa a
un è così di oggi 100 punta [ __ ] di
cose che non sai su di me il challenge
non dimentichiamoci delle challenge io
che non bevo per 24 ore io che non
mangio per 24 ore
io che non dormo per 24 ore no che non
diventa un coro per 24 ore o il classico
dei classici che cosa cede il mio iphone
e con questi ti dirò i premi di
contenuti non vuoi che non vengano
invitati alle fiere alle anteprime dei
film alle conferenze sul marketing di
fronte a un mare di giornalisti che
aspettano trepidanti cosa farà mai da
dire sul marketing un ragazzino di 14
anni si sente sa si sente sa e io mi
trovo qui oggi come rappresentante di
youtube italia
e ho un canale da 450.000 iscritti
inspiegabilmente io io io sono il canale
che faccio le challenge perché mi
piacciono i miei scritti e loro mi
dicono che devo fà faccio i tag
faccio gli ha un che non so bene cosa
voglia dire ma siccome lo fa negli anni
letti lo faccio pure io
cosa c'è nella mia borsa cosa c'è nella
mia camera cosa c'è nel mio buco di culo
e quindi cari giornalisti ios nuovo una
marea di persone alle fiere alle sagre
perché sono belloccio ci sono domande
lei col dito medio alzato dica però sono
tutti bravi ragazzi alla fine sono
contento per loro e quindi acciderbolina
anch'io voglio fare blog ad agosto per
farli più facili partiamo subito quella
più semplice cosa c'è il mio cellulare o
cavolo su due chiamate perse e un
messaggio da parte di paypal sono
arrivati i soldi di youtube perché
dovete sapere che quello che guadagno e
grazie al vostro supporto e soltanto
grazie al vostro amore che io guadagno
una marea di soldi al mese ma comunque
inspiegabilmente abito ancora con i miei
genitori
grazie ho trovato la foto del mio primo
album e di due anni fa
c'ero solo io questo perché i miei video
erano imbarazzanti siccome non mi
seguiva nessuno non potevo permettermi
di fare un raduno vero e proprio adesso
che faccio un sacco di disegno cure in
vendita i network e si sono attivati
adesso riempie i palazzetti dello sport
questa è la prima volta che mi sono
scovato una tredicenne e lo sono
avvocato mi ha detto che il legale ma
purtroppo l'età media e questo è più
alto non posso andare ma mi ha detto che
non è una sua prima volta che devo bene
mi stanno arrivando un sacco di motivi
più su twitter sai cosa facciamo
possiamo fare una foto ai miei scritti
piace quando ogni tanto durante la
giornata faccio una foto grande
arrivò subito mamma solo quegli scritti
sto facendo vive lo saluta di mamma mi
raccomando spulciate per marmaglio tosi
purtroppo il tempo a nostra disposizione
è finito anche oggi io vi ringrazio
tantissimo e vi ricordo che grazie alla
fanta alla red bull alla coca cola e
alla pepsi saremo ospiti alla fiera del
carciofo secco di pordenone giovedì
prossimo mi raccomando chiedete i vostri
genitori di essere accompagnati perché
ci sarà un sacco di sorprese e di
prodotti placement ora scusatemi che mi
sta chiamando uno sconosciuto pronto
certo che voglio fare libro della mia
vita un sacco di cose da dire